john violin joins us from washington he
was america's ambassador
in moscow between the years 2008 and
2012 president obama's first term
ambassador bailey very good to talk to
you i'm
very much looking forward to your
analysis of this summit but let's start
um with the fact that it happened at all
there are voices quite a few voices in
the united states saying that
the joe biden shouldn't have accorded
putin the the honor of uh having his
first summit as as president do you
think it is positive that it happened
i do think it is positive and uh i would
go back to something president biden
himself said
uh there's no substitute for
face-to-face dialogue
uh we haven't had face-to-face dialogue
uh of this kind with
vladimir putin for for quite some time
uh sitting down at the table with him uh
ensuring that he has to account for his
actions
making clear that you don't uh buy some
of the
facile explanations that he puts out for
what russia did or did not do uh all and
also making sure that he understands
what the consequences will be if he
continues actions that uh
injure american interests although
that's very important you can't do that
uh via telephone calls you can't
certainly do it by press statements
okay so i i fully get what you're saying
there you can be more direct i suppose
and there's
less chance for misinterpretation i
don't want to ask you because you've
seen this
you've seen that meeting between the two
gentlemen happened haven't you when you
were
ambassador vice president biden met uh
president putin or was he prime minister
putin at that stage that brief
interregnum
anyway what was the exchange what was
the atmosphere like between them
well he uh was prime minister at that
time when uh
vice president uh biden came to moscow
in 2011 when i was ambassador
um president biden vice president biden
prepares uh very assiduously for these
meetings uh he reads a lot we had a lot
of briefings ahead of time
we tried to run through everything that
he might expect
from uh vladimir putin putin will always
throw a surprise at you from time to
time as he did during that meeting
uh but uh biden is somebody who has been
around the block a time or two
uh he knows what the value of these
meetings are
and he also realizes really that the uh
success of a summit meeting is not
immediate
uh the success of the summit meeting is
measured not by what happened in the
meeting by but by what happened
after i think biden today even said he
quoted that great english proverb
uh the proof of the pudding is in the
tasting uh
they started to make the pudding today
but we won't have a chance to taste it i
think for another
uh for weeks or months ahead okay well
let's
talk about progress or not in in some of
the areas and let's start with the
traditional reason why the
the united states and the ussr and then
russia always used to meet which of
course is nuclear arms has there been
any progress on arm's limitation
the progress on arms limitation actually
happened
very soon after president biden was
inaugurated when he called vladimir
putin
and agreed to extend the
start the new start treaty which was
concluded under president obama
which was due to expire in a matter of
weeks uh he and putin agreed to extend
that for another five years
that that's absolutely critical because
it provides
the uh verification the data exchange
the monitoring that we
both of us need to make sure that we
have good line of sight on
each other's uh nuclear arsenals so that
was done
actually before this meeting what came
out of this meeting i think uh
which seems to be important but again
we'll see what it leads to is agreement
to broaden the dialogue between both
countries
uh in terms of strategic stability and
that means
not just the arms control on the nuclear
arsenals that we have today
but the whole generation of weapons
conventional
and nuclear that both sides are
developing
a very high tech hypersonic that need to
be factored in
if we are to maintain the level of
deterrence and visibility that has kept
us
basically safe for the last 50 years
okay ambassador
we're going to continue this but i'm
just uh alerting you and
obviously our viewers are seeing it
we're showing live shots of geneva
airport
and you talk about cutting-edge
technology rather old technology there
that old 747 air force one
uh on its way back now to the united
states the president has been
on european soil for almost exactly a
week that g7
summit then the nato summit then an eu
summit
and uh finally this summit with the
russian leader
well ambassador what about those
warnings
that joe biden was explicit about that
he was bringing to
president putin and first of all these
cyber threats
to the united states they've they've
moved on from
perhaps meddling in elections to direct
attacks
ransomware attacks on american companies
and indeed international companies
yeah i think the jury is still out on
whether the russian government is
responsible for the ransomware attacks
or whether they're
just turning a blind eye to criminal
activity in their country but in either
case they're directly responsible uh for
this and they could easily put a stop to
it
i think what president biden surely did
in the meeting was made very was make
very clear to vladimir putin
what the cyber capabilities of the
united states
are and if this kind of activity
continues if
he putin doesn't put a stop to it what
he might
expect uh the counter moves from the
united states to be that's something
that uh
biden won't talk about publicly he won't
be explicit about what that
would be but uh you can i'm quite sure
that he was explicit with vladimir putin
uh in a way frankly that putin probably
hasn't heard for the last three or four
years
and what about this issue of human
rights in
russia in particularly you know
democracy and alexei navalny
voluntarily yes he did return to
russia president putin said in his press
conference he wanted to get
arrested so we obliged him he didn't say
that bit
but that warning from joe biden that
should alexei navalny mysteriously die
in prison there will be huge
consequences
this is something that i think putin
understands already i mean these are
issues frankly that we were talking
about uh in 2011
in the meeting not mr navalny personally
but uh
the sort of shift towards uh a managed
democracy in russia and it's gone even
beyond that now
uh joe biden really is uh under no
illusion at all
what vladimir putin is trying to do in
russia
but i think the point that biden uh made
and i'm sure he was insistent on this in
the meeting
was that russia will pay a long-term
price for this uh
in terms of the investment that it needs
in terms of
the relationship with other countries
that it needs to counter china because
russia can't counter china on its own
uh i think biden went into that meeting
trying to see if there's any chance at
all that uh
putin is still interested in having a
more positive
less uh obstructive relationship with
the united states
and uh again we'll see
whether this uh amounts to any change in
in putin's behavior
in the weeks and the months to come but
it seems pretty clear to me that uh
biden laid down some
fairly uh sharp markers on these points
just flip it around for me ambassador
given your knowledge of
russian public opinion how will
president putin spin this
uh you know is it kind of well we may be
a second rank at best economic power
but we're still able to sit down with
the big boys
it's very important for uh putin the the
russian elite
uh in the government in business uh
in the academic world they expect the
russian president to be able to manage
some sort of relationship with the
united states
uh in which the united states isn't
essentially uh telling them to
sit in the corner until they uh can
behave better
uh so for putin this was important uh to
have the meeting but he's had meetings
with every u.s president
uh i think biden is the fifth president
now that he's
met with and so
for the the uh i think for the russian
public
the fact of the meeting is important but
they too
will want to see whether this results in
some material change
if sanctions are lifted if american
investment begins to flow more robustly
into russia this will all be measured on
the russian side as well
and putin will be judged by it